greetings from podcastville you [__]
suckers it's monday the 19th
of april we're [__] almost to 4 20
but before we get started
the joint today is brought to you by
blue chew
listen sometimes you need a little some
extra
to make your little soldiers stand at
attention there's nothing to be shameful
about you understand me
i'll let you in on a little secret get
blue chew and combat all forms
of erectile dysfunction blue chew has
the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis at a fraction of
the cost
bluetooth brings you the first chewable
dick pill
it's easy and all totally legit no
[__] snake or visits
no [__] horn whatever you get these
people
[__] start [__] dusk and [__] i
don't know
it don't matter blue chew is an online
prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations
no [__] eye contact with the doctor
and most importantly no waiting online
at the pharmacy the process is simple
you sign up at bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers and voila
once you're approved you will receive
the prescription
within days it's shipped right to your
door you understand me in a discreet
package
the mailman don't know dick nobody knows
nothing blue shoe tablets are made in
the usa
and prepared and shipped directly it's
way
cheaper than any [__] pharmacy that
you're gonna use
blue chew is the way to go now you're
sitting there going joey come on you
know i'm 24.
i got dick for days well what you know
what it's time to have dick for weeks
with blue chew why not go in there and
put a [__]
you wanted to walk home going what the
[__] was that
all right and today they got a special
deal for you try blue chew for free
joey what are you talking about free
[__] free when you use promo code
joey
at checkout just pay five hours for
shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey and you receive your
first month for free
and as always i want to thank buchu for
sponsoring the joint
and you [__] savages for using
bluetooth
the church is also brought to you by c
b d lion listen to me they're having a 4
20 sale use my promo code joey
or church and you're going to get 35
off i've been telling you about cbd lion
for years i've been telling you about
what they did for me during my surgery
and how it works for me and how easy it
made my recovery
now it's time for you to use cbd line
whether you have anxiety whether
you have pain whether you're having
insomnia
cbd lying can help you okay go to cbd
line
right now read the third party lab
results
what they're gonna do is if you spend
over 75 dollars you get a gift and
you can register to win the playstation
5 giveaway
go to right now cbdline.com
read they're gonna have the 420 sale
35 off and to co joey or church
and get 35 off cbd line delivered
right to your [__] house who's
better than cbd lion
nobody whether it's the bath ball the
roll on the
[__] gummies the chocolate
they'll bring that cbd cbn cby
to you so right now go to cbdlion.com
right now
pressing joey and get 35 percent off
for that 420 cell which only lasts till
tomorrow
now it's time to start the [__]
joint candles lit [__]
blue chew and cbd lion let's do this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 19th
or the 18th who the [__] knows what it i
think it's the 18th i hope it's
it's for 19. that's right the 19th a
beautiful
[__] day to be alive i had a great
let me tell you something it was a great
[__] weekend uh
she had three hits again the team lost
but
it's not whether you want to lose it's
how many [__] points you score we all
know that well that [__] case
but it's uh it's been a lot different i
wanted to tell you guys about my week
last week it was [__] up
i had two auditions last week you got to
put auditions on tape
now they're a [__] nightmare i've
been putting them on tape for a few
years and
i'm good at it but that's still a
[__] nightmare
and they've been a nightmare more and
more the last couple years because
you cannot read this lines with your
glasses on
it's very unprofessional they cannot
tell so you have to know
your [__] lines right so i
gotta know my lines
so i got two auditions the same week one
was for a cuban [__] dude
okay which i never get auditions for a
[__] cuban dude
and one was for a [__] italian dude
where i had to speak
[__] italian right i don't know i
took two years of high school italian i
don't know
i don't know about italian right so you
know i didn't want to put it on mike i
i was struggling with it you know it's
very
weird lately that i read [__] and i
could memorize it
i can't my memorization is [__] gone
from this pandemic i'm getting better
and better
and i'm taking my alpha brain but still
it's [__] a little on the rub
side never mind [__] a language a
different language i gotta
so i had this uh [__] up
situation where my wife i finally went
to my
wife like wednesday afternoon and i was
telling her about it i go you know i got
to put these auditions on tape and
they're [__] rough one's a cuban dude
and the other is a [__] italian dude
but that's speak italian i don't even
know where the [__] to start
so my wife says [__] it let's just work
on it let's work on it tonight
and let's do it so she helped me a
little bit wednesday night
tuesday night i had worked on it by
myself and thursday i got up
[__] dragging dick like i don't want
to [__] do this right
we finally did them i did both of them
i had a change i had to [__] comb my
hair a certain way i had a [__] you
know
because one dude was 1970 the cuban
trying to comb my head to the side and
you know
look at me i don't look [__] cuban so
i had to convince them like i know the
lady
so i had to explain to them like listen
it took me a while to do this audition
because i was trying to grow a mustache
but then i realized i can't grow a
mustache like most people
in [__] three days i got friends that
become the wolfman in two days
i couldn't do nothing i couldn't do that
so i left it just enough and i shaved
around it
but even with the thing but then later
on when i looked at the [__]
tape before i sent them my wife goes
they're both great you know you want to
take a look at it and i go i hate
looking at myself
and finally i looked at myself and holy
[__] i go
when i went to the gym thursday they
told me i lost another three pounds i go
jesus christ i'm losing too much [__]
weight too quickly i'm sticking to these
points
and i'm not eating pizza and [__] and
i'm working out i saw the size of my
[__] nose and i'm like jesus christ
look at the size of that [__] bugle
on your face i mean
that thing is [__] huge i've lost
weight over here so it's made my nose
look like michael jackson
i'm the greatest hits album have you
ever seen the greatest hits of michael
jackson before he's got the [__]
pigeon before the surgery his noses from
here to here
and let me tell you something i'm gonna
tell you a funny story that i told the
guys on patreon
i'm gonna be honest i can with you when
i was about from 1988
to the time i got from the time i got
out of prison to about 1997
98 i don't know when how long i'm just
letting you guys know this is how
[__] crazy
the coke ain't add me i wouldn't snort
coke with people with a big nose
like if somebody had a big nose like a
chick had a big nose you ain't coming
back to my hotel room because in my mind
that [__] could put away some cocaine
you understand me so i [__] didn't
[__] around with people who had big
noses
i still remember one time in miami it
was this cute girl but she had one of
those little [__] hook noses
and she was talking [__] and i'm like
listen
i'll take this girl back to hotel
whatever would do some coke
and i'm like you know what this chick
looks like she could [__] out snort
me
i'm not gonna bring her look at that
[__] hose on her face so for years
i had a [__] problem with people who
had a big nose and cocaine i just would
avoid him if i saw somebody who had a
big nose i'm like
i'm not doing coke with them that's how
[__] crazy i was
on the [__] drugs just to let you
know but
i do this thing on patreon i did it one
time and i was gonna do it again this
week this is the f
you know life is [__] weird how it
works out
you know uh i was gonna do it again i
did this
thing about angels on patreon last month
where
i put a picture up of a friend of mine
who died and i tell you the story of how
he affected my life you know
and last month i was gonna do anthony
balzano and this month
believe it or not i was gonna do dominic
special
so when i get the call for the italian
audition i'm sitting there rubbing my
[__] head and i'm like who am i going
to call for this
in the last 10 years i've only gotten
one other italian audition it was for
boardwalk empire
and i called this girl when i was a kid
i had a friend dominic speciale and
anthony balzano anthony balzano died
in may of 8 of 78. and this is why i'm
[__] up if you want to know why i'm
[__] up
uh and anthony died first then my mother
died in november
of 79 and then dominic died
in august of
80.
so i lost three friends once in a while
i didn't want mike to have to
superimpose it up here
and then you people are like oh you
stole from [__] john
oliver whatever so i just brought a
picture this is
this is my brother dominic speciale he
died
on august of 1980. i still got his
picture
he's on my ancestor table i light a
candle for him every week
i lost you know when he died he had an
older brother and he had a younger
sister
and i was tight with the older brother
but he uh
i lost contact with him after i left you
know after i left jersey in 80 83
i lost contact with the older brother
and i never really thought about the
little sister
from time to time i would go i wonder
how vida is doing i wonder how
you know she's doing and can you believe
in 2007 i'm doing tom lycus
and out of nowhere he takes callers tom
like us on his radio show
and [__] uh they go you have a caller
that wants to talk to you
her name is veda she said that she grew
up with you and i'm like
are you [__] kidding me put it
through
and you know she put it through and
she's like coco how the [__] are you
this is veda i'm dominic's little sister
i grew up with him like jesus christ i
remember you i still remember her
like coming around and dominic chasing
her away because she was younger we were
doing something we were lighting
something on fire or something
and she would walk up to us with a
little dress and little shoes on
so i've been tight with veda since 2007
she came to my wedding in 2009
she did the whole [__] thing you know
so whenever i get in the town like
even for the soprano movie anything i
have to do italian
when i'm reading the lines or when i'm
preparing for the movie i'll contact her
and say is there something i could say
here is there something
now i'm gonna play for you guys what i
had to learn okay
this is what i had to listen to for two
[__] nights in a row i just want to
tell you that
just so you know that i'm not a [__]
hack or whatever
i try to prepare the most i can you
ready
this was on loop all night and i'm
sitting there
and i would just catch um
this is what i had to do over and over
three hours tuesday night
three hours on wednesday night i had a
[__] italian headache listen to this
this is her so i'll call her send her
the lines
and she'll [__] send it back to me
so this was over and over i had to do
this over and over i [__] turned this
off i'm about to lose it right now
[__] that's why i listen to monday and
[__] tuesday over and over and over
and
over and i had to catch up with the
words and you heard me i was fumbling
them just now
so i had to [__] do it i had to get
up until thursday morning
and start all over again coffee and that
investigate
i didn't even know what the [__] i was
doing and brother when i got at that
last line because there was a bunch of
lines i had to say that's just the
beginning of it [__]
you have no [__] idea when i dropped
that last line
the [__] i could feel like the headache
and everything just go the [__] away i
was like jesus christ
that's what was giving me a [__]
migraine headache this italian over and
over and over and over
it was seven hours of her on loop going
oh and there's three different sets of
[__] sides guys
so next time you see me and you're like
joey looks a little uptight this is what
the [__] i have to deal with
as soon as i finish that it's like
i sent them both in and then i had a
[__] change in my head do
change my shirt and do the [__]
spanish one and do the [__] cuban one
and that one was a room filled with men
like it was one of those
where it's it's eight different people
talking at once i don't have to tell you
how
how [__] up that audition was so i
just broke it down to as small as
i can i just took it so that it was one
line me
one line and it just went to me i had to
rewrite it i don't give a [__] that they
get mad at me and i did a speech before
i go look i know i don't look [__]
attacked cuban to you
you know you want me to come over here
and talk like ricky ricardo and the
whole [__] thing
and i go i have a jersey accent i even
explained the whole [__] bay of pigs
on the [__]
on the honda i love torturing people
with the
pigs but on the [__] audition video i
even showed them that
they got the bay of pigs ready in a
training camp
right here in newark i have the
newspaper article from 1950 [__]
1960 it's on the bar right now as we
speak
yes it's on the bar there's a newspaper
article that somebody found
and he goes i don't know what you want
to do with this if you want to frame
this or not
and it was just a [__] article on the
newark ledger
that's not even a newark ledger anymore
it's like the jersey star ledger or some
[__]
but it was from [__] these uh how
they were taking cubans and training
them in the mountains of new jersey and
[__] like that
so i even went into that i go the reason
why i have a new jersey accent
is because i was trained in the
mountains of [__] queue of new jersey
i wrote my own [__] story for these
people so they're looking at this tape
right now going
what the [__] did this guy do listen i
don't even care about the role
i just didn't want to let my agency down
and you know
then they stopped sending me the [__]
out they'd tell me what i had to put on
board because they do a lot of things
and i want to be part of those [__]
things i want to be on board with those
people so
i wanted to let them know no they do
them here i wanted to let them know that
i'm here now i'm on the east coast and
that um
you know they just do work on the east
coast so i just want to let them know
i'm on the east coast
and i'm doing my thing and that's why i
put on tape i'm not listen i'm not
expecting to get
this [__] italian roll but it's
better than not doing anything you know
what i'm saying it's better than not
doing anything that's
and it's just it was just a [__]
great week all together
then we rolled into you know i wanted i
want to do each podcast every month
on the 19th i want to do a one-on-one
podcast with you guys
because it's going to be called you know
nine months after
eight months after today's eight months
from the day that i left los
angeles and
it has been a [__] miraculous
change i mean miraculous for myself
my wife and my daughter this has been
a period that i needed you know i also
made the decision on
not rushing into stand-up it was bad
enough i rushed into a podcast
but i had to keep doing something and
how to stay active i didn't want to rush
in to stand up
i wanted to take a breather i wanted to
really [__] be out there you know i
was telling mike
before we started the podcast that this
last weekend
um and i wouldn't even tell you
[__] this because i don't want
you to think that
you know anything i don't ever want to
do a podcast and talk down to you guys i
love you too much
i just share these stories with you so
you know what i'm going through you
understand me
i don't tell you these things because
i'm trying to be better than you guys or
nothing
i read an article two weeks ago you guys
all saw it
but you all saw an article about rudy
sarzo deserves to be in the hall of fame
or whatever
just for his work with quiet riot never
mind ozzie
and then white snake and all this [__]
so i called him up to congratulate
him he was putting my monsters a rock on
that week anyway
and we got into a conversation he goes
hey i saw you playing the guitar
if you ever want to do a lesson i go but
rudy you're a bass player he goes no i
know the guitar left and right
he goes you know with randy and then
everybody else he goes to play the good
bass
i got another guitar and he started
talking about the piano and all this
[__] and i'm like
i love to do a [__] uh i love to do a
[__] podcast
whatever with your zoom and just play
the guitar for you right
so it was friday morning and i
went to the gym and i set it up for
afterward he he's an early riser
and i think we set up at 12 o'clock i
went to the gym i ran
home i drank a little protein shake and
i came downstairs i set up the amp
i set up the guitar and it was
it was completely different than what i
was expecting
he didn't even he just told just he goes
i want to see you play
the guitar so
i play and i know a lot of people like
you got a [__] guitar lesson from
rudy saizo
listen it wasn't nothing like that he
was just doing me a favor like he just
it's like a favor you know so all we
went through and i'm i
apologize right now to that stupid [__]
i did on
instagram with the guitar because i
didn't want you guys to think i didn't
respect the guitar i do respect the
guitar
i respect the guitar like i respect
stand-up comedy and i was telling
mike that once the
lesson started he goes let me just see
you play with your playing
i showed him what i was playing brain
stew and black and black and [__] uh
nutshell at the beginning and and he
goes just let's learn a [__] d
chord and he taught me this d chord high
and he goes first off
i want you to put your elbow against
your [__] thing and do not move it
from there
he goes that's a bad habit to get into
that guitarist raised her elbow do not
raise your elbow
he goes take your fingers and he goes i
want you to use them you have fat
fat fingers and whatever you're not
pressing hard enough he goes i want you
to put your
finger behind the guitar and i want you
to use it
like a vice grip this is what i want you
to when you're pressing
i want you to [__] i'm getting
callouses on this finger already it's
[__] tremendous
you think i was finger banging it's a
crackhole or something i'm getting like
a little missile on my finger i'm
feeling it right now
um and he just showed me all these
little things
how he wanted my wrist you know how my
hand how to play
and then he went into this whole theory
thing
that guys it was so intense it was so
[__] intense
i had to go in my drawer and take a
football like
the anxiety was so [__] much
but it just goes to show you of
what and how you have to think to get up
to that
level in life of anything whether it's a
plumber
a mason a cook a chef a guitar player
you see the intensity you know you don't
you didn't you guys didn't want to talk
to me
15 years ago on my views of comedy
you did not you would have not liked me
my views on comedy
my views on the science of comedy is a
very
hard torture chamber if somebody i love
comes to me
and says to me i want to learn comedy
the
brutally honest talk i'm going to have
with them
is either going to make them quit or
inspire them
because i'm i want to i wanted to let
you know we are not running a [__]
game here they're not running a game
you know years ago after i did the
longest yard i
i was working tempe a lot i could do
tempi the guy in tempe
was [__] crazy remember we laughed
about him on the podcast
right you when i said rest in peace
[__] or something he was [__]
out of his mind
i forget what the guy's name was it
doesn't matter but
i was working tempe a lot and
there was a dog kid there and you know
he came up to me one day and he's like
man i like what you do
you know can you talk to me about comedy
and i was like absolutely
so he actually paid me for a room to go
to tucson
he goes i have a room in tucson can you
do the room
so he goes do you mind if i go out to
lunch with you and my mom
you know and i go no you know bring your
mom if you want whatever
i went to tucson i got checked into the
hotel and then i met him
and his mom for lunch and his mom he was
a young kid
he must have been 20 21 22
and they wanted to ask me questions
about comedy
if it was him by himself i would have
spoken to him
in a i spoke to him in an
honest and authentic way no matter what
but i let him know what needed to be
done
if he was going to be a [__] comic
like i tried to help him like
this is what needs to be done when i was
with rudy the other day i felt the same
way
like if you're gonna play the guitar
this is what needs to be done
like this is no [__] joke i don't
want you to think that you know
and the great thing about me is i have
no illusions of grandeur
it's not like i'm 22 and i'm thinking i
want to join white snake
i'm going to learn the guitar in four
years i'm going to put a band together
this is not for this for me it's been
really relaxational
it's bringing me back it's entertaining
me it's killing time during this
pandemic
and i'm learning something at 58 i'm
actually learning something i'm still
keeping my fingers coordinated with my
[__]
brain i'm trying to do something you
know i was in such a rough shape
you know eight months afterward i was
just i was in such rough shape every
week
i had been getting better and better you
guys have seen it i have been getting
better
and better i took for a while i thought
i had a mild heart attack
then once i did the surgery i realized
there was no [__] mild heart attack
then we're through with the [__]
surgery that's in the past we got the
vaccine so
every week i get better and better i
sleep more
i eat better you know i exercise more
i'm doing auditions every week but it's
taken me
eight months from the [__] beating
you know that was la
when i talked to that kid that day i
could see like he was petrified
afterward
and that's what you need to be i want
you to
know what you're getting yourself into
whether you're playing the guitar
whether you're gonna
go to vocational school what are you
gonna the highest level of commitment
is necessary for you to be the best and
i knew that i always knew that with
comedy
i in 2009 when i thought about getting
away from comedy
when i thought about it and then all of
a sudden the podcast
opened up all these opportunities i
strived to do one thing and that was to
be the best comic i could be
i wasn't trying to be better than bill
burr i wasn't trying to be better than
dave chappelle
i wasn't in a war with [__] kevin
hart
none of that [__] i was just working on
me that's all you need to worry about
is how am i gonna [__] you know i
met comics and musicians and i've met
people that
you get so caught up in what this guy is
doing and what that guy is doing or
i got to get the comedy store no you
don't you just got to get on stage
get on stage and in time you'll get to
the comedy store
but you got to get on stage don't go up
there i gotta talk tommy
you're not gonna get that you're just
gonna get frustrated you're gonna get
angry
and it's gonna [__] cloud your vision
just get on stage
when the store is ready for you the
store is ready that's a mistake a lot of
people made
but what i'm trying to get at here is a
couple of years ago in l.a
you know like for me i was i was burnt
out i
and i had i had no [__] clue right
now i'm telling you that i was burnt out
i had
no [__] glue today i don't feel burnt
out but i'm not ready to go back to
comedy i'm forcing myself
to get used to my life here to be a
family man here i mean
sadly i went to a softball game at first
i got up in the morning when i had
worked out friday i had done all my
weight watcher points so i got up
saturday morning and i went for a little
walk
like i told you guys i'm doing a little
walking therapy i didn't have to lift or
anything
then i took her to [__] mma class
then we came back with family we had
lunch as a family we goofed
around i think we sat outside and stuff
was still warmer
then i went and did the [__] softball
game at the softball game
two of my childhood friends showed up
one of my childhood friends showed up
with his wife
and their grandson to watch my daughter
play and then
i was there with parents of
a girl that we get along with that's
tight with mercy
and next thing you know two other
parents that have boys
showed up that are our friends just to
support the girls
so now we had four sets of [__]
parents you know
now that it's four o'clock and they're
like what are we going to do do you want
to go to a restaurant do you want to go
to somebody
the one lady says why doesn't everybody
come over to my house with all the
pizzas
whatever we went and ended up going back
we ended up ordering a ton of [__]
barbecue and they had cheesecake and
[__] french fries and macaroni and
cheese and whatever did i go off the
deep end no
my point is that [__] if it did if i
was living in l.a
that never happened that never happened
well i got together with four [__]
sets of parents and we just talked and
just giggled and just cracked [__]
jokes it was tremendous
nobody was smoking weed nobody was doing
bong hits nobody even smokes back there
nobody even brought it up i wasn't even
high while i was there i was just
[__] being normal trying to be
[__] normal something i haven't been
in years and now that i have the chance
to [__]
to have a normal [__] life and then
all of a sudden it's 6 30 and i'm like
looking at the clock and i go terry
you know how happy i am that two years
ago i would have probably had a [__]
leave right now because i would have had
a spot at the ice house somebody had an
early spot at the comedy store
i don't have to go nowhere we could sit
here and just hang out with the kids do
you know how nice that [__] feels
do you know how nice it felt when we
came home and we we put on cobra kai
last that was saturday night and we
watched the last two episodes
she [__] cried and then we watched an
episode of big city greens
back the honeymooners wasn't on because
the mets had a [__] double header
my point is that i'm finally enjoying
what the [__] is going on in my life
or the other option was you know what i
would basically have
been doing i would have called them at
two from a hotel room
and said what's going on and she's like
we're here at the field and i'm here
with this person and this person and
this guy
showed up you know how bad i feel in the
hotel room then
i'm missing my daughter's [__] life
because i'm doing comedy in some [__]
town and
trust me i'm not complaining what i'm
saying is that
this is how i was living my life and i'm
happy to be living a little different
now
eight months later you know i hadn't
been happy in la
it hit me while i was here i've been
here and i've been journaling and i've
been trying to write a [__] book with
erica and
you know this is all still going on me
and eric i still talk three days a week
and
this is still [__] on i mean we're
still on just
the podcast isn't the only thing i'm
[__] doing being a dad is not the
only thing i'm doing you know i am
doing other things like i said we have
auditions
we're doing the [__] book but it's so
weird how
i didn't know how burnt out i was until
i got here
you know a couple years ago something
happened i never complained about it i
never
talked about it on the church i'm going
to talk about it now right now that it
bothered me
i didn't know how much this bothered me
to recent
and while i was getting my head together
it came up
i don't know how many years ago robin
williams killed himself you know god
rest his soul
uh i'm not gonna sit here and tell you i
was best friends with robin williams i'm
not gonna
sit here and tell you i was a big fan of
robin williams i'm gonna sit here and
tell you that
i met him one time at the improv i met
him in 1983 in [__] snowmass village
he smelled like death he was doing coke
and he ran away from me when we asked
him to sign the box to moscow on the
hudson
you know i wasn't friendly with him i
didn't know anything about him i
respected what he did
and i knew he was a comedy store guy so
because of that
i had to give him the respect that he
deserved for years people said he was a
joke deep listen they didn't steal none
of my jokes
i never met the man so that was it i'm
at the improv one night
maybe two years before he died maybe a
year before he died
and he was just a meek little old man
and i was standing there with rogue and
he came over and he shook my hand
he shook joe's hand he said it's nice to
meet you whatever i just came down here
to watch you
well he was talking more to rogan he
wasn't talking to me he shook my hand
after rogan to be honest with you
and um he was just very nice you know
but then
all these articles and all these things
i started reading all these [__]
things about
comics and the dark side of comedy and
that's what really pissed me off
didn't piss me off like kind of hurt my
feelings when cnn
did a [__] like a thing about you
know the dark side of comics
and i tried watching it for a little
while and then i was like you know what
i'm not watching this because first off
i've been proving my i've been trying to
[__]
prove to myself all my life that i'm not
[__] crazy
now here's somebody else raising their
hand saying that i'm [__] crazy i'm
not [__] crazy
okay you know you're making a sound like
with some whiny [__]
that after we do comedy we go home and
we [__] we're in the dark and we
[__]
think of ways to kill ourselves i think
well no it isn't
the only time i struggled like that was
from 92
to 95 96 i was crying because how
[__] cruel the world was and what i
was going through with my daughter
and how frustrated i was with comedy but
after all that pain went away in 98 i
was fine
i was just a regular comic who was
addicted to drugs there was no dark side
of it
i had the addiction before i got into
[__] comedy so don't blame [__]
comedy
for my [__] cocaine addiction i
brought that [__] into my [__] coat
into my comedy world i had nothing to do
with it you know
so when i got into comedy i i was
looking into it because it was dark
i didn't get into comedy because it was
[__] happiness i was getting into
comedy because
there are drugs there are [__]
venereal diseases
there are [__] you know this is the
reality of it
i didn't get into comedy to be a [__]
priest i got into comedy because i
wanted to [__] check
out nobody gets into comedy because they
wanted to be a priest to change the
world or nothing like that
i just wanted to [__] check the [__]
out so
from society not from life i'm not
meaning from
my life i'm not suicide king here i'm
just trying to [__]
you know add light to this thing but
when i saw that that they did like a
three-part series on cnn i'm like
why are they [__] we already have a
ton of [__] stigmas in our business
i already have enough insecurities i
don't need for cnn to tell me i'm
[__] crazy because robin williams
killed himself
it just ate away at me but i will tell
you one thing
i will tell you the dark side of comedy
you know what the dark side of comedy
really [__] is
it's not comedy it's not doing stand-up
comedy
it's hollywood it's hollywood
it's that little stupid
pressure that hollywood puts on you
i didn't i worked against it as
much as i could but you couldn't [__]
succumb you
you you still couldn't fight it all off
it
that desperation that's in the air
that little desperation that the agents
have
other comics have people when they talk
to you you know after the podcast
it's a different world it's not like you
were on a tv show when i'm on a tv show
and my name is chuck
and i'm part of a cast i'm playing a
character on a tv show
when i'm on a podcast i'm not playing a
character i'm this is who the [__] i am
so doing all these things brought out
different things and people
are you following what the [__] i'm
talking about here this isn't this isn't
this is how i felt
there wasn't no dark side of comedy the
dark side of comedy is depression that
hollywood puts on you
those stupid things you know lately at
night once a week
or three nights a week they show i'm
dying up here on
showtime i did like two episodes of that
that show uh well yeah and my wife
called me she's like hurry up you're on
the episode i go
let it go i don't want to see myself on
the [__] episode but
it looks at the comedy store from a
different perspective
and what i and it lets me look at it now
without seeing the comedy stuff for a
year from a different [__]
perspective
and i'm looking at it and i see the guy
that rape ray romano's brother i forget
what his name is he plays
one of the characters and he plays a
down and out
uh 50 year old that has been playing in
vegas
you know and he is now
looking to go into business with the
lady who's playing mitzi shaw
but throughout his to second season you
could see this guy is snapping
and at one point the mob played by yours
truly comes to him
and says they need their money back or
they got to be partners on his
venture and he has to pay them whatever
doesn't really matter
my point is that he snaps one night and
he goes
you don't understand i just want to get
off the [__] road
you know somebody brought him something
that he was a bad parent and all this
[__]
and he's like i just want to get the
[__] off the road
you're out there [__] around lost you
know to the outside eye it looks like a
lot of fun
and it really is and it's supposed to be
fun
all you're supposed to do how can how
can there be a dark side
to something that is so [__] fun how
can there be a dark side to it
to something that is so [__] pure and
light-hearted
that if you go up there and you just
crack jokes and you have a good time
it's
it gets dark when [__] promoters and
[__]
club bookers and agents and that's
the dark side of comedy when those
[__] get involved
and one person is telling you one thing
and the other guy's telling you that
thing and you don't even [__] know
and don't get me wrong there's no dark
side to comedy
there's a dark side to music too you
don't think i was the as what do you
think about last week i was
goofing around with you [__] people
about [__] i don't [__] around with
sharon osbourne
you know i wasn't i'm not making fun of
sharon you know i feel bad for [__]
whatever
what i'm saying to you people is that
look at just take
take the forget about black sabbath
forget about ozzy osbourne
let's take uh ccr what's the [__]
guy's name john
the singer john fogerty have you ever
heard this story how he gets no money
from ccr he wasn't allowed to sing ccr
songs
what do you think that does to you as a
[__] when all you want to do is sing
all i want to do is sing all i want to
do is play the drums
all i want to do is play the harmonica
all i want to do is play the violin
all i want to do is play the skin flute
and all of a sudden all these people
are now all you want to do is comedy all
you want to do is comedy and people go
no you can't do that venue
can't do that venue because there's not
enough tickets can't do that one because
there's too many tickets
you can't do this one because the
[__] union so
that's that's what my dark side was it
wasn't what i was doing at all by no
means
was it what i was doing the dark side of
comedy to me was
the agents the [__] club men the
owners the managers the bookers the
promoters
you know three thousand you know you so
you you i was looking over my [__] like
i was dealing with [__] criminals
half the time
i had to look over my [__] like i was
dealing with [__] criminals after
[__] time
can you believe that people that i'm
some you know these are like movie
people
nice decent white people i gotta look
over my [__]
because this they're always beefing they
always got three hands in the [__]
bowl
it's it's amazing it's so that's
the dark side of comedy you know my life
changed
listen there was a rough bump in my life
and it was july of 2016.
and that's when i shot degenerates and
i'm thankful for netflix
for giving me that i'm i'm not going to
sit here i'm thankful for [__]
everything
i'm very thankful for netflix for giving
me the half hour opportunity
what i wasn't thankful for was how the
opportunity came abroad
and the things that happened while and
it wasn't netflix's fault you know whose
fault was it it was my fault
i didn't see the writing on the wall i
got blinded by the [__] smoke i'm
but i'm a big boy and i admit that now
i got blinded by the light i thought
that all this [__] was going to happen
from me doing a half hour special shame
on me
shame on me those are my expectations
but that was a big lesson for me but let
me tell you what it did
that plane ride home from vegas after i
shot the netflix special
and after the door went down after
christina got up there and
the sound and all the [__] from that
night
that plane ride home was a very crucial
time for me
because it let me know if i was going to
do this i was going to do this on my
terms
and it made me a way better [__]
stand up than what i was
it made let me tell you something in
2019 i was very good guys
i could sit here and blow smoke up your
ass i'll tell you one thing and you know
i tell you when i bomb
i tell you when i have a upset i'm not
hitting i'm not one of those comics i
killed tonight no you didn't
i wasn't there you didn't kill me you
didn't [__] kill you you ate a bag of
dicks but if you killed
if you thought you killed uh good luck
to you i'm not gonna i'm not here to
argue with you
i tell you when i eat a bag of dicks
nobody eats a bag of dicks like me
and it was very rare in 2019
like i said the other day yeah i ate a
bag of dicks in new orleans
and maybe a couple other cities but let
me tell you something i look at those
notebooks
and i know what i was saying i know it
was coming out of my mouth and i was
writing down the result
i was having great shows in 2019
and the beginning of 2020 i was in my
[__] i was on a [__] roll
and if you people saw me in atlanta you
know i was on a roll
if you people saw me out and when i was
in vegas i was on a [__] roll
and you [__] who saw me in
tempe of in 2020
that weekend i [__] killed all five
[__] shows because i was looking at
it
before i talk [__] i have a notebook
that i write everything to [__] down in
and i was kicking the [__] ass and it
was all because of
what i felt in 2016. but with all that
in mind
i was still [__] burnt out and don't
get me wrong what i'm doing is taking
time off from stand up
nobody said i was quitting i got a
little high on those [__] pills in
the beginning
and i said i was retiring i'm not going
anywhere what i'm doing is taking a
breather
which is going to make me that much more
stronger every time i play that [__]
guitar
it irks me to [__] write something
the last two nights
listen every [__] night saturday
night i put the ufc [__] fight on
and i practiced my [__] guitar the
only fight i watched was the
gasterman uh the australian fight
the other four fights i was icing my
knee for one fight
and pretensing it and then the other 15
[__] 20
30 minutes i was practicing the [__]
guitar and guess what
i ended up writing something about the
fight so i am writing [__] jokes
i'm not ready to go back out there you
know the [__]
jewelry goes into the liberation today i
think on the [__] shelving case
god knows where we're gonna go there in
this [__] country
so before all that [__] happens jesus
christ
i might as well uh just take some time
off
and look at it it's done me [__]
great guys i feel great
i look great my attitude is [__]
better
you know i'm when i want to go to a
comedy club like rich voss
god bless her soul i love that
[__] you know
if you ever get a chance to see him he's
ever enjoyed support him
because the help that he's given me
between him and florentine has been
tremendous
but rich foss calls me all the time he
goes anytime you want to come to one of
my shows
if you just want to sit and watch or if
you want to do a guest spot
you're more than [__] welcome the
other night i'm not going to lie to you
ufc night i was threatened to go to
[__] tiffs
because there was no [__]
honeymooners and i was like pissed off
that there was no [__] honeymoon so i
was like
maybe i'll go to tips and do a guest set
but
i'm not doing that i owe uncle vinnie
three sets before i do anything
so when i'm [__] hot and ready and i
can see it already that
this little breather and me playing the
guitar i told you guys
for you to be creative you have to
entertain if you
don't get entertained it's tough to be
[__] creative
you gotta you know and listen for me
it's not pete like i wish i could tell
you that i watch a
a netflix show and i get [__]
motivated that doesn't motivate me
anymore
you know a biography motivates me you
know
something like that motivates me but me
watching [__] tv
doesn't motivate me at all that doesn't
entertain me a good movie like the night
a bunch of guys hit me up this week at
close range was on the other night oh my
god
i had the f you know i just get into
movies i'm an old movie nut
and i don't talk about movies on this
podcast as much as i should
but like i think it was yeah that was my
gift for doing those two podcasts
for doing those uh two auditions
thursday night in the midst of my
migraine when it went away i was like
what am i gonna do tonight
and i went to see what was coming on and
like ten o'clock
at close range was coming out i'm like
jesus [__] christ
i [__] went in there i played the
guitar from nine
to nine fifty nine nine fifty nine i
[__] took two hits off the [__]
pipe
and i sat the [__] down and i watched at
close range
from a to z and you know what man
it i'm a real fan of good acting
like i [__] love watching great
acting
when it's people that i like
i [__] lose my mind and i was like
you know what man
look at [__] christopher walken look
at sean [__] i mean i watched the whole
thing
and then during the middle i'm not gonna
lie to you during the middle i got a
little
bored and i went back because i wanted
to practice [__] brain stew again
because i'm trying to get my fingers to
stretch out so i practiced it again but
at the last scene when he [__] goes
in with the gun
and tries to get christopher walken then
i went back and i [__] paid attention
and i got all [__] intense and my
palms got sweaty and i'm like
all right i gotta turn this off now
cause i'm not gonna be able to go to
sleep
but i did [__] fall asleep so
everything worked out as [__] planned
but that's it man we're here eight
[__] months it's crazy it's been that
long eight
[__] months has come and gone
i wish i would have given the guitar to
you sooner you know i had that in
december i was like i don't know if he's
gonna be interested in this
i wasn't i wasn't really i really i
really wasn't worried about it i'm just
happy that uh
that we came i'm happy that i i got to
look at myself from what the [__] was
going on
you know i should have been the happiest
i ever was
after 2016. you know and i wasn't
and i noticed that people around me
there was a lot of comics around me some
were faking the funk
but i could see some comics were just
caught up like i knew
of two comics that were just [__] up
that i was talking to constantly
and they weren't feeling it and now when
we talk
we know what the [__] it was that we
were feeling
we were [__] burnt out you know there
is a dark side to comedy
there is a dark side to music there's a
dark side to plumbing
there's a dark side to everything you
[__] do if you let yourself get taken
there
if you let yourself get taken there
there is a dark side to everything
there's a listen man i know women who
strip and end up [__] up
and i know women who strip and end up
leaving with a [__] mercedes-benz
they put 50
000 away in a down payment on the condo
and they walk away
unscathed there's other strippers that
[__] become strippers and
then you see them 20 years from now
they're toothless with tattoos and biker
tattoos on their necks they belong to
you know who knows it's how what you
control it
you know i fell into it when i got into
comedy i fell into the cocaine and
i could blame the store i could blame
the road i could blame the improv
no i fell into the dark side on my own
you know what i'm saying
and my my dark side was cocaine which i
cleaned up
and then the rest of the dark side was
once i got involved in hollywood i
realized
how much i really didn't like and how
much it really wasn't who i am
i just got into this game to do stand-up
comedy i didn't get into this game to go
to premieres
i don't look at i don't like looking at
myself on a [__] camera
i'm like all this [__] you know on
youtube i go on youtube when i'm [__]
answering emails or something like that
and i just put the youtube page on you
know
sometimes it's an old video of the
church or something
and i'll go jesus christ let me watch it
i'll watch it
the longest i can watch one of those
church videos is maybe 50 [__]
seconds
and i go what who the [__] was that guy
and i look at the date and i go what the
[__] was i talking
about and more importantly what the [__]
how many drugs did i do that day
how many edibles did i do that day how
many [__] joints did i smoke that day
what was it really [__] necessary i
mean
not i had a great time i'm not listening
it was a great [__] podcast it was
great that
you know but what the [__] you know i
just caught a podcast the other day uh
that i went and the reason why i
retweeted it was because
i was like in shock we were talking
about just put [__] on the [__]
ice cube
lee was like this ice cube tastes funny
i don't know what the [__] he was
talking about a sugar cube
a sugar cube we had liquid acid putting
it on a [__] sugar cube on a [__]
podcast on a national [__] podcast
that's seen all around the world you
didn't even remember that it's called
the acid check
yeah we didn't even you know it's like
that was one of the many
[__] acid days like i look at those
podcasts and i'm like what did i do that
day
what did we do who gave us a pill who
gave us
you know a [__] ketamine who thought
you know what the [__] what are we
thinking
and listen again you know me dog i ain't
bitching about doing drugs i enjoy i'm
no [__] quitter
but you have to evolve in your life and
i feel great now like today it's
what is it 10 in the morning i still
haven't [__] smoked up
you know i still haven't smoked up i'll
smoke before too i adhere to the rules
i wrote the rules i got to add to them
but it's not like i used to get up and
[__] i would drink a cup of coffee
and then i would be
two three bung hits in and then i would
be you know all day i could hear him the
wheeze in my throat yeah i still got the
wheeze on my throat and i got the
beginnings of emphysema
i know that you don't need to [__]
tell me that but i do sound a lot better
today i feel a lot better
i'm walking a lot better i got my
walking on i can tell when i'm breathing
so
i'm very happy i made this [__] move
so eight months later
it has been as positive as i thought it
would be hey all right i'm not doing
stand-up but i'm doing a [__] podcast
and i'm learning how to [__] be a dad
i'm just
adjusting to learning how to being a
[__] dad and you know what last time
i checked
there ain't nothing wrong with that
especially after i failed the [__]
first time
at least i'm humble enough and and man
enough to say i [__] failed i
i couldn't come through for my child but
this time
it's going to be different it is
different and that's why i'm doing the
things i'm [__] doing
so i'm happy that you [__] watched
today
uh i'm happy that we got to open up a
monday i know that you guys have been
[__] uh
how come you got a guest on a monday
okay listen i'm coming on here and i got
something to say
it's been eight months and this is what
the [__] has happened and this is how i
feel
so i'm happy that you're [__]
watching guys i'm happy that you uh
are seeing the change in me you're
seeing what's going on here
and in time we're just gonna keep
getting stronger and better and
we're gonna put guests on whether you
like them or not that's not my [__]
problem
uh that's up to you to decide i'm just
gonna keep doing my [__] job
and keep doing what i'm doing being
honest with you [__] that's the
best thing i could do
so it's monday the 19th i've been here
for eight months
thank you for all your support thank you
for watching and i will see you
[__] thursday
with a guest just so you [__] know a
good guest we're gonna have a great
[__] time and i don't know what i'm
doing for 420
yet happy 420 for all these i know cbd
lions got a sale i talked about in the
beginning and at the end i know that
i'm gonna try to do something with uh
i know that my man is doing something
that
be real is doing something with cypress
hill and it's going to be a pay-per-view
event
i mean i would jump on it if i was you
it seems like it's going to be a lot of
fun you know i love being real
we were supposed to do each other's
podcasts but he's been rehearsing and
you know we've been trying to put it
together i don't know what's going to
happen today
if maybe i could go on there today and
do a segment but uh
happy 420 to all you [__] i'll
be doing something i'm gonna surprise my
patreon people
but that's all i got for you
[__] have a great week
have a great monday and i'll see you
[__] tip top magoo
wednesday morning 7 7am as usual
have a great [__] day and now for a
word for my [__] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you
[__] for watching on a
beautiful
monday morning thank you for hear
beating i gave you i know you guys are
like joey the guests they're back
so [__] mondays i'll come to you
direct to start your week off
on the right foot before we leave i want
to talk to you about something cbd line
is having a huge
420 sale right now it goes on till
tomorrow what are they gonna give you
they're gonna give you
35 percent off when you use code joey or
church who's better than uncle joey on a
monday nobody who's better than cbd lion
nobody if you use if you spend over 75
hours
they're gonna friend send you a free
gift and remember
that you can still register to win the
playstation 5
until april 30 at the end of the month i
don't know if there's 31 days on april
30 i don't know my [__] calendar in
front of me what i'm telling you is
register right now to win a playstation
it's hard to [__] find
and cbd lion's got one for you cbd lion
420 sale
the best and the code joey cox is
35 off the joint is also brought to you
by
blue chew joy what's blue shoe blue chew
blue chew is the first chewable dick
pill it is blue
and it tastes tremendous why would i
need that joy why because sometimes
you need a little extra [__]
something to make that little soldier
[__] stand up
at attention nothing to be [__]
ashamed about i'm 58 years old
i had a pop one last week you know i'm
saying nothing to be ashamed about
but i'll let you know a little secret
you get blue chew and you combat all
forms of erectile dysfunction
they have the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis
at the fraction of the cost and it's
easily and totally
legit and there's no [__] here it's
an online prescription service
blue with blue chew there's no visits to
the doctor's office
there's no awkward conversations there's
no eye contact
there's no waiting online there's no
[__] nothing
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
and you talk to one of the licensed
medical professionals
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it comes
discreet
there's no pictures of dicks or sad guys
walking down the street on the [__]
envelope
it's a discreet package the envelope the
mailman don't know dick nobody knows
dicks
not even your wife or no dick bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped directly it's
way cheaper than a pharmacy even if you
don't have erectile dysfunction
you want that missile to be [__]
ready you understand me
at all [__] times you're ready to get
a good [__] dick sucking
with bluetooth.com so do me a favor go
to bluetooth.com right now and
enter promo code joey to receive your
first month
for free they got a special deal for you
try blue chew free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
and just pay five dollars for shipping
that's it
that's bluetooth.com promo code joey to
receive your first month
for free free free and as always
i want to thank blueshoot for supporting
the podcast
i want to thank bluetube and i want to
thank cbd line do not forget to go to
cbd line
for that 35 off and that's it and that's
that i love you [__]
thank you for listening thank you for
watching have a great day and have a
great [__] 420.
that's it that's how you end the [__]
podcast [__] have a great day
[Music]
so
you